lithium battery looking to fill more  than a dozen full-time positions with  benefits and 401k there's a job fair  tomorrow it's from  nine to noon at 1350 wigwam parkway  it will even train qualified candidates  looking for assemblers and operators to  work in their new  manufacturing facility then on tuesday  the 22nd  arizona charlie's will have an  on-the-spot hiring event  it is at the decatur location from 10 to  2. 1 000  signing bonuses and bus passes are up  for grabs  for a full list of companies hiring in  the valley and there's a ton of them  head to eight newsnow dot com click on  the job board tab we put together a list  with all of those jobs and links to  apply